[Música]
la guerra en ucrania cumple hoy tres
meses sin que el ejército ruso haya
logrado doblegar a la resistencia en
ucrania en el donbass donde controla
toda la costa que lleva la península de
crimea y también con las negociaciones
para el cese de hostilidades congeladas
el objetivo del presidente ruso vladimir
putin era derrocar el gobierno de
ucrania liderado por el presidente de
9000 selenski también y así instaurar un
nuevo gobierno que fuera favorable a sus
intereses sin embargo rusia no contaba
con la resistencia del ejército y de la
población ucraniana ukranian tiene el
apoyo de gran parte de la comunidad
internacional liderada por eeuu y los
países miembros de la unión europea
estas naciones no han intervenido
directamente en la guerra pero han
proporcionado armas ucrania y también
han implantado sanciones económicas para
así perjudicar al gobierno ruso e
intentar disuadirlo de estos ataques de
acuerdo con el más reciente recuento el
alto comisionado de naciones unidas para
los derechos humanos al menos a tres mil
900 personas han muerto durante este
conflicto más de 13 millones han huido
dentro
fuera de ucrania para ello entonces
quiero saludar a dos de nuestras
invitadas del día leticia álvarez e
irene sabio pues son enviadas especiales
de france 24 durante toda esta guerra en
ucrania irene y letizia gracias por
estar nuevamente en nuestro espacio de
france 24 directo américa quiero empezar
contigo letizia haciendo más un balance
lo que sigue está que estos tres meses
estos tres meses de conflicto
bueno
ucrania ha pasado estos pasados tres
estos tres meses escuchando de un
conflicto que pensamos que iba a ser muy
rápido que iba a ser una invasión rápida
y que iba que no iba a tener muchas
bajas simplemente iba a derrocar el
gobierno que había en ese momento y que
sigue estando de lenski y hemos pasado
de eso a tener una guerra que parece que
se va a enquistar que va a durar mucho
que ahora mismo es una guerra de dos
ejércitos cara a cara una guerra como en
la segunda guerra mundial una guerra de
artillería una guerra de muchas bajas de
militares y que está destrozando
ciudades completas en el este del país
que es donde se está concentrando la
mayoría de
todos esos ataques y la guerra más cruda
más fuerte es ahora mismo en el donbass
así que hemos pasado por distintas
etapas y ahora se prevé que sea una
aunque los ucranianos quieren una guerra
que termine pronto
después del verano se prevé que vaya a
durar porque rusia lo que quiere es
tomar todo el donbass y toda la zona sur
y bueno buscar ya no está dispuesto
ahora en estos momentos a acceder más
territorio todavía a rusia claro quiero
ir ahora con irene irene le quiero
preguntar cómo ve entonces esta guerra y
también que ha cambiado durante estos
últimos estos últimos tres meses no
buenas tardes si realmente estoy de
acuerdo con lo que estaba comentando
letizia no hay que olvidar que en la
primera fase de la guerra teníamos una
guerra total no en todo el país con
algún asedio sobre la capital sobre
quién ataques también aéreos en este
momento por ejemplo está esta estrategia
militar está siendo menos usada es una
guerra terrestre en la que se está
viendo en el este del país y por tanto
ha habido ha habido cambios importantes
rusia misma ha
indicado no nos da un poco
informado de sus planes de sobre ucrania
aunque por supuesto hay muchísima
propaganda de ambos lados lo que es una
certeza y antes se escuchaba el
escuchaba las cifras que han dado los
medios que han citado lo que es una
certeza es que esta es una guerra que
continúa cobrándose la vida de muchas
personas civiles y también militares y
son cifras realmente que van creciendo y
que desconocemos incluso los ucranianos
y los rusos probablemente desconocen con
la precisión en nuestro reportaje nos
hemos encontrado por ejemplo con las
dificultades que se están teniendo para
identificar a los cuerpos de algunos
combatientes por la intensidad de la
guerra en estos momentos
dificultades que se deben a la
brutalidad de este conflicto con lo cual
lamentablemente no hay un
no se pueden hacer una previsión es muy
positiva sobre un desenlace
rápido
[Música]
pacífico en un corto plazo claro leticia
cuál es la cuál es la situación de los
civiles y digamos ustedes que han estado
por tanto tiempo en ucrania cubriendo o
cubriendo todo este conflicto que
tendría que pasar para que esta guerra
para que esta guerra realmente termine
crees también letizia que las
posibilidades de acabar ese conflicto de
la forma diplomática
está fuera de la mesa
bueno yo personalmente creo que si el
conflicto se tiene que determinar de
forma diplomática y con negociaciones y
con diálogo no hay no hay otra cavidad
no pueden haber derrotados y vencidos
aquí pero es mi opinión personal para
que esta guerra termine ahora mismo
ay hay distintos hay distintas opciones
sobre la mesa una que occidente siga
dando ayuda a ucrania nivel de
artillería de armas de forma que pueda
ganar territorio en el este y que rusia
se vaya retirando pero eso tiene también
unos riesgos y es que rusia se sienta
todavía el vladimir putin más amenazado
y acorralado con lo que exista la
posibilidad de que haga un ataque aún
mayor con otro tipo de armas que
implicaría unas respuestas todavía
mayores a nivel internacional así que la
solución no es fácil pero yo
personalmente creo que pasa por por la
diplomacia y sobre todo esa diplomacia
hemos visto que ha funcionado al final
no en los inicios ha funcionado para
evacuar a civiles ha funcionado también
en la acería de mariupol aunque ahora
mismo no se está produciendo ese
intercambio de prisioneros pero pero se
ha producido un alto al fuego y ellos
pudieron salir así que si hay una
solución tiene que ir por la vía del
diálogo
irene quiero ir contigo ya como para
finalizar nuestra nuestra conversación
que concluye digamos de todo lo que
ustedes dos han visto de todos los
reportajes que han hecho y titán y
también teniendo en cuenta como la
población civil no que son los que más
sufren en esta guerra y también en le
quería preguntar qué tan cierto es que
pues las cosas en kiev están volviendo
de cierta forma a la normalidad
las conclusiones son conclusiones de
momento en inconclusas en cierto sentido
porque todavía estamos con un conflicto
en curso lo que lo que sin duda
es en este momento es una certeza es que
se trata de un conflicto convencional
que estamos viviendo en el siglo 21 y
esto es realmente
algo que probablemente muchos de incluso
de nuestra generación nos esperaban a
vivir en él
en europa en estos momentos entonces
esto sin duda es una conclusión que creo
que no sé si letizia comparte pero qué
por qué podemos hacer claro
personalmente varios refugiados la gente
está volviendo a ucrania porque quiera
retomar sus vidas y la situación es más
tranquila pero siempre está ese contexto
en el que puede caer un misil por
ejemplo en un colegio o en un centro
comercial hacer rasilla allí pero la
gente no quiere renunciar a sus vidas